Another thing Dr. Bright is not allowed to
do at the Foundation: Dr. Bright is not allowed
to send e-mails with memetic hazards attached!
No, not even when replying to spam!
Dr. Bright.
We don't care how annoying it is when your
inbox fills up with suspicious links, Linda's
annoying Quote of The Day, and chain letters
telling you that you have to forward the email
to 10 people or have bad luck for a year.
That doesn't make it okay to reply with SCP-2774
attached!
That goes for any other memetic hazard.
The last thing we need is more instances of
these hazards floating around in cyberspace.
Take a breath, stand up from the keyboard,
and let the spam filter do its job.